what up space fam golson here from anime
out pro and i'm
back at it again to discuss the latest
developments in the one piece story
and this is full speed ahead craziness
right now so make sure to stay tuned for
that
if you enjoy seeing these one-piece
reviews and want to keep them coming
the best thing you could do is smash
that like button and share this video if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one-piece
reviews and videos
as you wait for future chapters to drop
feel free to check out my one piece
playlist link in the description
where you can find videos about the
yonko supernovas warlords and more
leave suggestions in the comments if
you'd like me to cover any other grouper
topic
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
this week's shonen jump issue cover is a
tribute to one piece it seems that this
is the 23rd anniversary since one piece
started and what a mind-blowing 23 years
it's been
one piece is by far the best selling
manga of all time and this is a big deal
that we don't always fully appreciate we
are living through a historically
significant point in manga history
one piece is a phenomenon that will be
talked about for decades and even
centuries after the story is over
and we get to experience this phenomenon
together week by week
on anniversaries like this i think it's
cool to step back and appreciate how
lucky we are that we get to be part of
this exciting history we also get a cool
color image of luffy kit
and law on two giant birds i like these
special images specifically because we
get to see the personalities of the
different characters at work
luffy is happy carefree grabbing some
food kid is competing with him over it
clearly he's bent out of shape as usual
it seems like kid is always reacting
more to luffy who's usually just messing
around and in their rivalry although i
love captain kidd
i feel like luffy has more of the pirate
king energy because he's just less
reactive he's at the cause and not the
effect
while law gets less caught up with the
competition between the other two
more like an introvert he's feeding some
birds on his own and he's
fine with riding on the same bird as
luffy he doesn't have to constantly
compete with him they say a picture is
worth a thousand words and with oda that
definitely applies
on to the chapter itself where we jump
right into the action this chapter is
called new onigashima project
so you know it's gonna spill some
important beans we start at the back
door of onigashima
where some of our guys are confronted by
the traitor kanjuro kundra obviously
knew that they'd be persistent and come
so he was ready for that we got plenty
of the red scabbars here to face kanjuro
including kawamatsu kiku rizo inuarashi
nekomamushi
ashura and even izo kundro says he won't
allow them to enter and he has a
sizeable team with him
so this is going to be one of the first
big group clashes of this war
our guys want to free momonosuke asap
and we get the story of what we've
already inferred before
kundra explains how momonosuke did his
best to free himself
he did take that knife he was looking at
freeing himself and tried to run away
when kundra tried to stop him momonosuke
stabbed him and then an angry kanjiro
beat the living daylights out of
momonosuke
kiku is clearly affected by this as are
the others even if they wear more stoic
expressions
kundru lets them know that momonosuke is
being publicly executed and that he just
has to stall them while the kozuki
bloodline disappears
it's funny how in the meantime inuarashi
and nekomamushi are having a
lighthearted combo about their new
modifications
it seems like nekomamushi has a gun
where his paw used to be i like that
they took this approach where they
turned something like losing a paw
into a kind of advantage like captain
hook but not evil and all
i can't help but respect these fighters
who injury after
injury keep coming back to fight again
mad respect for them kiku
then puts on an epic samurai helmet and
becomes the most
badass person ever kiku tells kundra to
shut up and sets and i quote you know
very well that the scars caused by my
blade
carry on to the afterlife right the
wound that i'm about to inflict on you
will torment your soul end quote that
must be one of the most epic lines
spoken in one piece
and i know the competition is stiff but
damn i
really love those words kiku attacks
kanjuro
and battling erupts we see that
inuarashi modified his legs into a blade
and now uses two sword style a very
creative way to fight and a style that's
very much at home
in the world of one piece we go back to
yamato and luffy
and we have some strong evidence that
yamato may well become the newest straw
hat member yamato straight up
asks if luffy will accept her on board
his ship here we might have some
translation issues but what appears to
happen is that luffy tells yamato
that she can't become odin odin was
another dude who was loved by many
people she can't just steal his identity
then yamato refers to luffy as odin
implying he
should then take on the role of the
legendary figure
from my perspective with this
translation it seems like yamato is
saying that someone needs to become odin
even if it's not her it's an interesting
idea where i suppose she's conflating
the need for someone to carry out odin's
will
with the need for odin himself let me
know your thoughts on this below
according to yamato with those shackles
she is not free
they may explode if she leaves and or
keep her from using her possible devil
fruit powers that would help her leave
yamato tells us that she wanted to leave
with ace
but since she was 8 she was forced to
stay on the island
interestingly enough luffy hasn't said
that yamato can't be a straw hat yet
he just said that she can't be odin
furthermore he seems to be finishing a
lot of the things that ace started in
wano
carrying out his legacy in that way with
helping out tama helping out wano
and now he may well free yamato and take
her to sea
if you think about nami and other straw
hats luffy is associated with freedom
and he does help his crewmates free
themselves
from present circumstances or from their
past he freed zoro from prison
nami from arlong sanji from his
self-doubts and procrastination and so
on wouldn't it make perfect sense
if he now freed yamato from kaido i
really think it would just be a natural
progression at this point
then it is in fact made clear that the
shackles are like the ones the prisoners
have
they'll explode if she leaves the island
she wonders if kaido would really do
that to his child
kaido being a terrible father is
something that i didn't see coming but
oda has really been focusing on that
aspect of the story lately
on a side note we see again how yamato
just towers over luffy she has those
giant kaido jeans for sure
yamato says that her father is the type
of guy to blow her up
if she leaves and disobeys him and
that's why she's scared to try and leave
luffy offers to take the shackles off as
he warns her that with her help or
without
it he's taking down kaido that
unwavering confidence after the results
of the first fight
never ceases to amaze me yamato explains
that she wants to beat him up just as
bad
since he beat her up every time she
opposed him and it seems like that's
what infuriates kaido that he can't
control yamato
and that she respects his enemy who he
had to cheat against to defeat
more than she does him her own father
this younger generation
rebellion is nothing new for one piece
as dragon and luffy did not follow
garp's wishes
and became criminals in the eyes of the
marines luffy says he'll remove the cups
as kaido begins his huge announcement
kaido talks about
the world government and their decision
to abolish the warlord system which was
helping to keep the world in balance he
talks about the marines being absolutely
confident
in their new power to deal with pirates
i love the political struggles and
maneuvering that happens in one piece
the marines seemingly have upped their
power and so kaido
ups his power he tells his men not to
worry since they are allied with another
yonko crew now
and are together going after the ancient
weapons
the weapons are game changers and world
enders we got pluton
a battleship poseidon which manifests as
the mermaid
shirahoshi who can control sea kings and
uranus which we know the least about so
far you can potentially use
each one of these weapons to rule or
destroy the world so with them big mom
and kaido would be
untouchable such a move makes the
government have to act as well as
everyone else
the question is can the marines use an
ancient weapon right now is that one of
the aces up their sleeves
or will every force begin to rush to get
one for themselves
the fact that there's three definitely
leads me to believe that different
forces will acquire different ones
and that may become its own balance of
power but the two
arguably strongest yonko and their crews
working hard with a one-minded focus to
find the ancient weapons
is a scary thought for any force in the
world it'll be a kick in the pants for
everyone
and arms race of epic proportions and i
said arguably too strong is because they
do have the highest bounties
but again we don't know what shanks is
fully capable of we see that nami
and carrot are not in a good situation
looks like zeus
is back in big mom's hands she's at full
power again
and there is a shared sentiment between
these yonko that if they work together
everything including the one piece will
be theirs a crazy announcement since the
one piece often tends to be this thing
in the background but it's finally
given a sense of urgency here there was
whitebeard who wasn't interested in it
and people like akainu who's not gonna
go for it
but now we have two yonko working
together to get it
a crazy goosebump inducing sense of
urgency comes with this announcement
kaido seems to be aiming for chaos and
fear throughout the world for a world of
violence
rather than wanting freedom like luffy
kaido seems to yearn after a survival of
the fittest kind of world
where he's the top dog then something
truly crazy but not altogether hard to
believe happens
kaido announces plans to take over
everything including the flower capital
as orochi becomes shocked and begins
complaining kaido
slices his head off to people's shock
and big mom's laughter
now perhaps orochi's mythical zone
through abilities will save him
since the yamata no orochi has multiple
heads
and usually when you cut off a hydra's
head for instance
it can grow back or even two can grow
back in its place
so it's too soon to say 100 oroshi is
dead but it seems
clear that he's powerless without
kaido's support no matter what
one of the things that stood out this
whole time was that orochi was just
getting to rule based on kaido's power
when kaido realized that orochi was no
longer needed and he had the power to
intimidate all of his forces into
joining him
he took action we learned that kaido is
a guy who waits until the odds are very
good and then strikes
that alliance definitely didn't end well
and it makes me wonder what will happen
to momonosuke now
would kaido execute him or was he
disgusted with orochi's cowardly idea
from the beginning
remember kaido even untied big mom for a
fair fight albeit he owed her but would
he really execute a tied up child
i'm not so sure as kaido gives orochi's
men the ultimatum of joining him or
dying and excited luffy seeing
momonosuke manages to fall from the
ceiling
down to the ground their confrontation
seems real close at hand right now
kaido continues not noticing luffy
saying that they are preparing for the
biggest world war
clearly showing that oda is making this
bigger than marine ford he's going to
turn wano into the
empire of piracy the flower capital will
be the new onigashima
crazy stuff we then jump to kanjiro and
kiku and others for a second
we see a bloody sword and tears flowing
from kiku's mask
as kaido pro claims that it is the end
of wano
the exact opposite of what odin wanted
clearly this is made to look like kiku
got conjured
a traitor but the way oda shows this he
could be purposely misleading us the
ambiguity
makes for an even more interesting
cliffhanger then as if enough
shocking events haven't taken place
already kaido says that yamato
the person who hates him will be the
shogun of the country newly named new
onigashima onigashima translating to den
of demons in english
yamato is infuriated by this and wants
to fight
and luffy wants to know the quickest way
to momo the shackles are still
on so hopefully luffy will take them off
soon
but wow what a chapter i feel like oda
keeps topping himself with these latest
chapters
and this is without a doubt my favorite
yet in this art i can't wait
to see what happens next let me know
your thoughts on this one and what
you're expecting for the next chapter
but damn oda did not disappoint
after 985 chapters he's got me on the
edge of my seat a genius of his craft
23 years in thank you oda for this
amazing adventure and thank you space
fan for watching yet another review
if you did enjoy it and like seeing
these reviews on the channel the best
thing you can do is smash that like
button and share this video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss
future one-piece reviews and videos as
you wait for future chapters to drop
feel free to check out my one piece
playlist link in the description where
you can find videos about the yonko
warlord supernovas and more and leave
suggestions in the comments telling me
what group or topic you would like me to
cover next lastly the youtube ad rates
have dropped big time
so the support we're getting from our
anime outpour patrons is very
appreciated
a very special thank you goes for
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these youtube issues and who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
on top all clans
stephen and grotta alola and atem do
world steelers acquire respect pate
heffa
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf the school bus king riser
emperor otaku ricardo martinez thomas
jones
ken mono michael hyde and jaden the
vector controller
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson kings eldris anatoly
kazotsky
angel cruz cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci alicia actor jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie parks
zodiar 12 orthu and de ora kraken
aurel's
and deadly saint thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime for a link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the youtube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you